President Trump may use his first
presidential pardon for controversial
former Arizona sheriff Joe a pyro the
Phoenix area lawman was convicted last
month of criminal contempt for detaining
people he merely suspected of being
undocumented immigrants Margaret Brennan
is outside Trump Tower where the
president is spending the next few days
of his working vacation Margaret good
morning good morning well as president
Trump tries to quiet one racially fueled
controversy he is weighing whether to
plunge into another one by pardoning a
controversial Arizona sheriff who was
convicted of illegally detaining Latinos
because he suspected them of being
undocumented immigrants the president
appeared to endorse the possibility of a
pardon this morning in a tweet and told
Fox News that he is seriously
considering issuing one within days now
Joe Arpaio is the 85 year old Arizona
sheriff who was found guilty two weeks
ago of ignoring a judge's order to stop
racial profiling during traffic patrols
that targets suspected undocumented
immigrants our Payoh has been a vocal
supporter of mr. Trump and he is
scheduled to be sentenced in October he
has become a hero among the far-right
civil liberties groups have long
complained about racial profiling and so
a pardon here would be well received
among some of mr. Trump's base who voted
for him on the basis of aggressive
immigration enforcement Norah the White
House isn't commenting on this yet they
don't have an official announcement but
this would be the first pardon of the
Trump presidency all right Margaret
thank you so much